You don't need me to tell you that
human civilization is very, very old.
Nevertheless, our knowledge of the
earliest stages of human civilization,
we're quite limited for many centuries.
That is until the great
archeological discoveries of
the 19th and 20th centuries,
which unearthed for us the
great civilizations of the
ancient near east of which
I have drawn and remarkably lifelike
map here on the board, Mediterranean,
we start with the Mediterranean
Ocean, the Nile river, the Tigris,
and the Euphrates. So the
great civilizations of
ancient Egypt, Mesopotamia,
and the area we refer to as the fertile
crescent of which a little part here
about the size of Rhode Island is Canaan.
Canaan,
Canaan and archeologists in the 19th and
20th centuries were stunned to find the
ruins and the records of remarkable
peoples and cultures. Um,
massive complex empires in some cases,
but some of which had completely
disappeared from human memory. Uh,
they're newly uncovered. Uh, languages
had been long forgotten. They're rich.
Literary and legal texts were now
undecipherable that that soon changed.
But because of those discoveries,
we are now in a position to appreciate
the monumental achievements of these
early civilizations.
These earliest civilizations.
And so many scholars and many people
have remarked that it's not a small irony
that the ancient near eastern
people with one of the,
or perhaps the most lasting legacy was
not a people that built and inhabited,
um, one of the great centers of
ancient near eastern civilization.
It can be argued that the ancient near
eastern people with the most lasting
legacy is a people that had an idea.
It was a new idea that broke
with the ideas of its neighbors.
And those people were the Israelites.
And scholars had come to the realization
that despite the Bible's pretensions to
the contrary,
the Israelites were a small,
and I've actually overrepresented it here.
I'm sure it should be much smaller,
a small and relatively insignificant
group. For much of their history,
they did manage to establish a kingdom
and the land that was known in antiquity
as Canaan, um, around the year 1000, um,
they probably succeeded in subduing some
of their neighbors collecting tribute.
There's some controversy about that.
But in about nine 22,
this kingdom divided into two smaller
and lesser kingdoms that fell in
importance. Um, the northern kingdom,
which consisted of 10 of the 12,
is relight tribes and known confusingly
as Israel was destroyed in seven 22 by
the Assyrians,
the southern kingdom,
which consisted of two of the 12 tribes
and known as Judah managed to survive
until the year five 86 when
the Babylonians came in
and conquered and sent the
people into exile.
Capital Jerusalem fell conquest and exile
were events that normally with spell
the end of a particular ethnic national
group particularly and antiquity
conquered peoples would trade.
They're defeated God for the
victorious God of their conquerors.
And eventually there would be a
cultural and religious assimilation
intermarriage that people would disappear
as a distinctive entity and effect.
That is what happened to the 10
tribes of the northern kingdom.
To a large degree.
They were lost to history.
This did not happen to those members of
the nation of Israel who lived in the
southern kingdom.
Judah,
despite the demise of their
national political base in five 86,
the Israelites alone really among
the many peoples who have, uh,
figured in ancient near eastern
history, the Sumerians, the Acadians,
the Babylonians, the Hittites, the
Phoenicians, the horigans, the Canaanites,
they emerged after the death of their
state producing a community and a culture
that can be traced through various twists
and turns and vicissitudes of history
right down into the modern period.
That's a pretty unique claim.
And they carried with them the idea and
the traditions that laid the foundation
for the major religions of the Western
world, Judaism, Christianity, and Islam.
So what is this radical new idea that
shaped a culture and enabled it survival
into,
uh,
into later antiquity and really right
into the present day in some form?
Well,
the conception of the universe that was
widespread among ancient peoples is one
that you're probably familiar with.
People regarded the various natural, um,
forces as imbued with divine power,
as in some sense divinities themselves.
The Earth was a divinity. The Sky was
a divinity. The water was a divinity,
had divine power.
In other words,
the gods were identical with or
imminent in the forces of nature.
There were many gods, no one single
God was therefore all powerful.
There is very,
very good evidence to suggest that ancient
Israelites by and large shared this
worldview.
They participated at the very earliest
stages in the wider religious and Celtic
culture of the ancient Near East.
However, over the course of time,
some ancient Israelites,
not all at once and not unanimously
broke with this view and articulated a
different view that there was
one divine power, one God,
but much more important than number was
the fact that this God was outside of
and above nature.
This God was not identified with nature.
He transcended nature and he wasn't known
through nature or natural phenomena.
He was known through history events
and a particular relationship with
humankind.
And that idea,
which seems simple at first
and not so very revolutionary,
we will see that's an idea that affected
every aspect of Israelite culture and
in ways that will become clear as we
move through the course and learn more
about biblical religion and
Biblical views of history. Um,
it was an idea that ensured the survival
of the ancient Israelites as an entity,
as an ethnic religious entity
in various complicated ways.
The view of an utterly transcendent God
with absolute control over history made
it possible for some Israelites to
interpret even the most tragic and
catastrophic events such
as the destruction of their
capital on the exile of
their remaining peoples,
not as a defeat of Israel's God
or even God's rejection of them,
but as necessary, unnecessary part of
God's larger purpose or plan for Israel.
These Israelites left for us the
record of their religious and cultural
revolution in the writings that are
known as the Hebrew Bible collectively.
And this course is an introduction to
the Hebrew Bible as an expression of the
religious life and
thought of ancient Israel.
And as a foundational document of
Western civilization, of course,
has several goals.
First and foremost,
we want to familiarize you with the
contents of the Hebrew Bible. Um,
we're not going to read every
bit of it word for word. Um,
we will read certain chunks of it quite
carefully and others we will work,
we will choose selections.
But you will get a very good sense and
a good sampling of the contents of the
Bible.
A second goal is to introduce you in a
to a number of approaches to the study of
the Bible. Different methodological
approaches that have been advanced, um,
by modern scholars,
but some of which are in fact quite old.
At times we will play the historian,
uh,
at times we will be literary critics.
How does this work as literature? Um,
at times we will be religious
and cultural critics.
What is it the Israelites were saying in
their day and in their time and against
who and for what?
A third goal of the course is to
provide some insight into the history of
interpretation.
This is a really fun part of the course.
The bibles radically a new
conception of the divine.
It's a revolutionary depiction of
the human being as a moral agent.
It's riveting saga of
the nation of Israel.
Their story has drawn
generations of readers to
ponder it's meaning and message.
And as a result,
the Bible has become the base of an
enormous edifice of interpretation and
commentary and debate both in
traditional settings but also in academic
university, secular settings.
And from time to time,
particularly in section discussion,
you will have occasion to consider the
ways in which certain biblical passages
have been interpreted. Sometimes I'm very
contradictory ways over the centuries.
That can be an it really fun
and exciting part of the course.
A fourth goal of the course is
to familiarize you with the,
the culture of ancient
Israel as represented in the
Bible against the backdrop
of ancient near eastern.
It's ancient near eastern setting.
It's historical and cultural setting
because the archeological discoveries that
are referred to in the ancient near east,
um,
reveal to us the spiritual and cultural
heritage of all of the inhabitants of
the region,
including the Israelites.
And one of the major consequences of
these fines is the light that they have
shed on the background and the
origin of the materials in the Bible.
So we now see that the traditions in
the Bible did not come out of a vacuum
there. Early chapters of
Genesis, genesis one through 11,
they're known as the primeval history,
which is a very unfortunate name because
these chapters really are not best read
or understood as history
in the conventional sense.
But these 11 chapters, oh,
a great deal to ancient
near eastern mythology.
The creation story in genesis one draws
upon the Babylonian epic, the, um,
known as a Pneuma Aly. She will be
talking about that text in some depth.
The story of the first human
pair in the garden of Eden,
which is in genesis two and three,
a has clear affinities with the
epic of Gilgamesh. That's, uh,
a Babylonian and Assyrian epic in which
a hero embarks on this exhausting search
for immortality.
The story of Noah and the flood,
which occurs in genesis six through nine
is simply an Israelite version of an
older flood story that we have found
copies of a Mesopotamian story called the
epic evoucher Hassis.
I'm a flood story that we also have
incorporated in the epic of Gilgamesh.
Biblical traditions have routes that
stretch deep into earlier times and out
into surrounding lands and traditions.
And the parallels between the biblical
stories and ancient near eastern stories
that they parallel, uh, has been the
subject of intense study. However,
it isn't just the similarity between the
biblical materials and the ancient near
eastern sources that is
important to us. Um, in fact,
in some ways it's the dissimilarities
that is remarkably important to us.
The biblical transformation of a common
near eastern heritage in light of it's
radically new conceptions of God and
the world and humankind will be dealing
with this in some depth. But I'll give you
one quick example for, uh, we have, uh,
a Sumerian story from about the
third Millennium Bce, right?
Going back 3000, third
millennium, 3000 BCE.
So story of Zeus Sutra,
and it's very similar to the
genesis flood story of Noah.
In both of these stories,
the Sumerian and the Israelites story,
you have a flood that is the result
of a deliberate divine decision.
Um,
one individual has chosen to be rescued.
That individual is given very specific
instructions on building a boat.
He's given instructions about
who to bring on board. Um,
the flood comes and
exterminates all living things.
The boat comes to rest on a mountain top.
The hero sends out birds to reconnoiter
the land. When it comes out of the Ark,
he offers a sacrifice to the god.
The same narrative elements, um,
are in these two stories.
It's,
it's just wonderful when you
read them side by side. So, um,
what is of great significance though is
not simply that the biblical writer is
retelling a story that was
clearly went around, you know,
everywhere in the ancient,
uh, in ancient Mesopotamia,
they were transforming the story so that
it became a vehicle for the expression
of their own values and their own
views in the Mesopotamian stories.
For example, the God's Act propitiously
the God's act on a whim. In fact,
I'm one of the stories that God say, Oh,
people, they're so noisy. I can't sleep.
Let's wipe them all out, right?
There's just, that's the rationale.
There is no moral scruples.
They destroy these helpless,
but stoic humans who are chafing under
their tyrannical and unjust and uncaring
rule in the biblical story. When the,
when the Israelites told the story,
they modified it.
It's God's uncompromising
ethical standards that lead
him to bring the flood in
an act of divine justice.
He's punishing the evil corruption of
human beings that he is so lovingly
created and whose degradation he
can't bear to witness. So it's,
it's saying something different. It's,
it's providing a very different message.
So when we compare the Bible with the
literature of the ancient Near East, um,
we'll see not only the incredible
cultural and literary heritage that was
obviously common to them, but we'll see
the ideological Gulf that separated them.
And we'll see how biblical writers,
uh,
so beautifully and cleverly manipulated
and use these stories, as I said,
as a vehicle for the expression of a
radically new idea they drew upon these
sources, but they blended and
shape them in a particular way.
And that brings us to a critical problem
facing anyone who seeks to reconstruct
ancient Israelite religion or culture
on the basis of the biblical materials.
Um,
that problem is the conflicting
perspective between the
final editors of the
texts and some of the older sources
that are incorporated into the Bible.
Some of the older sources that they
were obviously drawing on those who were
responsible for the final editing,
the final forms of the texts, um,
had a decidedly monotheistic perspective,
ethical, monotheistic perspective.
And they attempted to impose
that perspective on their
older source materials.
And for the most part
they were successful,
but at times the result of their
effort is a deeply conflicted,
deeply ambiguous texts.
And again,
that's going to be one of the most fun
things for you as readers of this text.
If you alert to it,
if you're ready to listen to the cacophony
of voices that are within the text.
In many respects,
the Bible represents or expresses a
basic discontent with the larger cultural
milieu in which it was produced.
And that's interesting for us because a
lot of modern people have a tendency to
think of the Bible as an
emblem of conservatism, right?
We tend to think of this as an old
fuddy duddy document. It's outdated,
has outdated.
Um,
and I think the challenge of this course
is that you read the Bible with fresh
eyes so that you can
appreciate it for what it was.
I'm in many ways what it continues to
be a revolutionary cultural critique.
We can read the Bible with fresh and
appreciate devise only if we first
acknowledge and set aside some of
our presuppositions about the Bible.
It's really impossible in fact that you
not have some opinions about this work
because it's an intimate
part of our culture.
So even if you've never
opened it or read it yourself,
I bet you can cite me align or two
and eye for an eye, tooth for tooth.
And I bet you don't really know what it
means. The poor will always be with you.
I'm sure you don't really
know what that means.
These are things and phrases that we
hear and they create within us a certain
impression of the biblical text and how
it functions versus our quoted there
alluded to,
um,
whether to be championed and valorized
or whether to be lampooned and pilloried.
But we can feel that we have
a rough idea of the Bible.
And a rough idea of its outlook when
in fact what we really have are popular
misconceptions that come from the way in
which the Bible's been used or misused.
Most of our cherished presuppositions
about the Bible are based on astonishing
claims that others have made on behalf
of the Bible claims that the Bible has
not made on behalf of itself.
So before we proceed,
I need to ask you to set aside
for the purposes of this course.
Some of the more common myths about the
Bible. I have a little list here for you.
The first is the idea that the
Bible is a book. It's not a book.
We get rid of that one,
okay?
The Bible is not a book with all that
that implies that it has a uniform style
and a message and a single author of
the sorts of things we think of when we
think in a conventional sense of the
word book. It's a library, right?
It's an anthology of writings were books
written and edited over an extensive
period of time by people in very
different situations responding to very
different issues and
stimuli, some political, some
historical, some philosophical,
some religious,
some moral.
There are many types or genres
of material in the Bible. Um,
there's narratives, wonderful narrative
stories. There's all kinds of law.
Their cultic and ritual
texts that prescribe how some
ceremony is supposed to be
performed. There are records
of the messages of profits.
There's lyric poetry,
there's love poetry. Um,
there are proverbs, there are
psalms of Thanksgiving and lament.
So there's a tremendous
variety of material in this
library and it follows from
the fact that it's not a book,
but an anthology of diverse works,
that it's not an ideological monolith.
And this is something a lot
of students struggle with.
Each book or Strand of
tradition within a book,
within the biblical collection sounds
its own distinctive note in the symphony
of reflection.
That is the Bible.
Genesis is concerned to account for the
origin of things and wrestles with the
existence of evil,
the existence of idolatry and suffering
in a world that's created by a good God.
The priestly texts and Leviticus and
numbers emphasize the sanctity of all life
and the ideal of holiness and ethical
and ritual purity there or odes to human
reason and learning and endeavor
and the wisdom book of proverbs,
Ecclesiastes. These reads like
an existentialist writing, um,
from the 20th century.
It scuffs it the vanity of all things
including wisdom and a spouse is a kind of
positive existentialism.
The psalms are very individual writings
that focus on individual piety and love
and worship of God job possibly
the greatest book of the Bible.
I won't give away my, my
preferences, their challenges,
conventional religious piety and arrives
at the bittersweet conclusion that
there is no justice in
this world or any other,
but that nonetheless were not excused
from the thankless and perhaps ultimately
meaningless task of righteous living.
One of the most wonderful and fortuitous
facts of history is that later Jewish
communities chose to put all this stuff
in this collection we call the Bible.
They chose to include all of
these dissonant voices together.
They didn't strive to reconcile the
conflicts, nor did we, nor should wake,
excuse me, nor should we. They didn't.
We shouldn't each book, each writer,
each voice reflects another thread in
the rich tapestry of human experience,
human response to life. And it's puzzles,
human reflection on the sublime and,
and the deprived.
And that leads me to my second point,
which is that Biblical narratives
are not pious parables about saints
not pious tails.
They're psychologically real literature
about very real and realistic people in
life situations.
They're not stories about pious people
whose actions are always exemplary and
whose lives should be models for our own,
despite what Sunday school curriculum
will often turn them into. Right.
And despite what they
would have us believe, um,
there is a genre of literature that
details the lives of saints hagiographies
but that came later and is, uh, largely
something we find in the Christian era.
It's not found in the Bible.
The Bible abounds with human,
not super human beings.
And their behavior can be scandalous.
It can be violent, it can be
rebellious, outrageous, lewd,
vicious. But at the same
time, like real people,
they can turn around and act in a way
that is loyal and true above and beyond
the call of duty. They
can change, they can grow.
But it's interesting to me that there
are many people who when they opened the
Bible for the first time,
they close it and he shock and disgust.
Jacob is a deceiver. Joseph
is arrogant, spoiled Brat,
Judah reneges on his obligations to his
daughter in law and goes off and sleeps
with a prostitute. Who are these
people? Why they're in the Bible.
And the shot comes from the expectation
that the heroes of the Bible or somehow
being held up as as perfect people.
That's,
that's just not a claim that's
made by the Bible itself.
So Biblical characters are real people
with real compelling moral conflicts and
ambitions and desires. And they can
act shortsightedly and selfishly,
but they can also like real
people learn and grow and change.
And if we work too hard and too quickly
to vindicate Biblical characters just
because they're in the Bible,
then we miss all the good stuff.
We miss all of the moral sophistication,
the deep psychological insights that have
made these stories have such timeless
interest.
So read it like you would read any good
book with a really good author who knows
how to make some really
interesting characters. Thirdly,
the Bible's not for children. I'm
a 12 year old, eight year old.
I won't let him read it.
I won't let it read it.
Those Bible stories for children books,
they scare me.
They really scare me.
It's not suitable for children.
The subject matter in the Bible is very
adult, particularly the narrative texts.
Um,
there are episodes of treachery and incest
and murder and rape and the Bible is
not for naive optimists.
It's hard hitting stuff and it speaks
to those who are courageous enough to
acknowledge that life is rife with pain
and conflict just as it's filled with
compassion and joy. It's not
for children. And another sense,
like any literary masterpiece,
the Bible is characterized by a
sophistication of a structure.
And Style and an artistry of seam
and Metaphor. And believe me,
that's lost on adult readers. Um,
quite often it makes its readers work.
The Bible doesn't moralize or rarely,
rarely moralize.
It explores moral issues and situations,
puts people in moral
issues and situations.
The conclusions have to
be drawn by the reader.
There are also all kinds of paradoxes
and subtle puns and ironies and a in
section where you'll be doing a
lot of your close reading work.
Those are some of the things that
will be drawn to your attention.
You'll really begin to
appreciate them in time.
The fourth myth you want to get rid off
the Bible is not a book of theology.
It's not a catechism or
book of systematic theology.
It's not a manual of religion.
Despite the fact that
at a much later time,
very complex systems of theology
are going to be spun from particular
interpretations of Biblical passages.
You know,
there's nothing in the Bible that
really corresponds to prevailing modern
western notions of religion,
what we call religion. Um,
and indeed there's no word for religion
in the language of biblical Hebrew.
It's just isn't a word. Religion.
With the rise of Christianity,
western religion came to be defined to
a large degree by the confession of or
the intellectual ascent to certain
doctrinal points of belief.
Religion became defined
primarily as a set of beliefs,
a catechism of beliefs or truth
that required your ascent.
What I think of as the catechism kind
of notion of religion that's entirely
alien to the world of the Bible.
It's clear that in biblical times
and in the ancient near east,
generally religion wasn't
a set of doctrines that you
ascribe to right to become
an Israelite later on,
a Jew,
the word Jew doesn't isn't something we
can really historically use until about
this time.
So most of our period we are going to be
talking about the ancient Israelites to
become an Israelite.
You simply joined the Israelite community.
You lived in Israelite life,
you died in Israelite death.
Do you will Betas or light law and custom.
You revered Israelite Law Lore,
you entered into the historical community
of Israel by accepting that their fate
and yours should be the same.
We'll sort of a process of
naturalization what we think of today as
naturalization. So the Hebrew Bible,
it just isn't a theological text book.
It contains a lot of narratives and its
narrative materials are an account of
the Odyssey of a people,
the nation of Israel.
They're not an account
of the d of The divine,
which is what theology means and
account of the divine. However,
having said this,
I should add that although the Bible
doesn't contain formal statements of
religious belief for systematic theology,
it treats issues,
many moral issues and some existential
issues that are central to the later
discipline of theology. Um, but
it treats them very differently.
It's treatment of these issues
is indirect. It's implicit.
It uses the language of story and Song
and poetry and paradox and metaphor.
It uses a language and a style that's
very far from the language and style of,
of later philosophy and abstract theology.
Finally,
on our miscount,
I would point out, well, I don't
really need to cross this out.
This is something to discuss.
I would point out that the Bible was
formulated and assembled and edited and
modified and censored and transmitted
first orally and then in writing by human
beings. The Bible itself doesn't
claim to have been written by God.
That belief is the religious doctrine
of, of a much later age. And even then,
one wonders how literally it was meant.
It's interesting to go back and
look at at some of the earliest, uh,
claims about the origin of
the biblical text. Similarly,
the so called five books
of Moses, Genesis, exodus,
Leviticus, numbers, Deuteronomy,
the first five books we called
the Pentateuch of Moses. Um,
nowhere claimed to have been
written in their entirety by Moses.
That's not something they say themselves.
Some laws and exodus, you know,
the book of the Covenant. A few things,
yes, it says Moses wrote those down,
but not the whole five books that
traditions later we'll ascribe to him.
The Bible clearly had many contributors
over many centuries and the individual
styles and concerns of those writers,
their political and religious
motivations betray themselves frequently.
I leave aside here the
question of divine inspiration,
which is an article of faith
in many biblical religions.
It's no doubt an article of faith
for people in this very room,
but there is no basic in compatibility
between the leaving on faith in the
divine inspiration of the Bible and
acknowledging the role that human beings
have played in the actual formulation
and editing and transmission and
preservation of that same Bible. And
since this is a university course and not,
you know, perhaps a theological course
or within the theological setting,
it's really only the ladder,
the demonstrably human
component that will concern us.
It's very easy for me to assert that
our interest in the Hebrew Bible will be
centered on the culture and the history
and the literature and the religious
thought of ancient Israel in all of its
diversity rather than quick questions of
faith and theology.
But the fact remains that the document
is the basis for the religious faith of
many millions of people and
some of them are here now.
It is inevitable that you will bring what
you learn in this course into dialogue
with your own personal religious beliefs.
And for some of you,
I hope all of you that will be
enriching and exciting. For some of you,
it may be difficult.
I know that.
And I want you to rest assured that no
one in this course wishes to undermine or
malign religious faith anymore than
they wish to promote or proselytize for
religious faith. Religious faith
simply isn't the topic of this course,
the rich history and literature and
religious thought of ancient Israel as
preserved for us over millennia in the
pages of this remarkable volume that is
our topic. And so our approach is
going to be necessarily academic. Um,
and especially given the
diversity of people in this room.
That's really all that it can be,
so that we have common ground and
common goals for our discussions.
But it has been my experience
that from time to time, um,
students will raise a question or
ask a question that is prompted by a
commitment,
a prior commitment to an article of faith.
Sometimes they're not even aware
that that's what they're doing.
And I want you to understand
that on those occasions out,
most likely respond by inviting you to
consider the article of faith that lies
behind that question. And it's creating
that particular problem for you.
I'm not going to be drawn
into a philosophical or
theological debate over the
merits of,
of that belief,
but I'll simply point out how or why
that belief might be making it difficult
for you to read or accept what the text
is actually and not ideally saying and
leave you to think about that.
And I see those as wonderful
learning opportunities for the class.
Those are in no way a problem for me.
All right,
so let's give a few sort of necessary
facts and figures now about the Bible and
then I need to a little bit about
the organization of the course.
So those are the last two
things we really need to do. Um,
an overview of the structure of the Bible.
So you have a couple of handouts
that should help you here. Um,
so the Bible is this assemblage
of books and writings.
I'm dating from approximately 1000 BCE.
We're going to hear very diverse opinions
about how far back this stuff dates
down to the second century.
The last book within the Hebrew Bible
was written in the one sixties BCE.
Some of these stories, some of
these books which we've, you know,
think roughly from a certain date,
they will contain narrative snippets
or legal materials or traditions,
oral traditions that may even date back
or stretch back further in time and they
were perhaps transmitted orally and then
ended up in these, these written forms.
The Bible is written largely in Hebrew,
hence the name Hebrew Bible. Um,
there are a few passages in Aramaic.
So you have a handout that breaks
down the three major components.
It's the one that's written
two columns per page, okay.
For the, we're going to talk in a
minute about those three sections.
So you want to have that handy.
These writings have had a profound and
lasting impact on three world religions,
Judaism, Christianity, and
Islam for the Jewish community.
So first compile these writings
in the pre Christian era.
The Bible was perhaps first and foremost
a record of God's eternal covenant with
the Jewish people.
So Jews refer to the Bible as the Tenakh.
So the term you see up here,
um,
that should be also on that sheet tena
which is really the letters to me and um,
and they put little A's in there to make
it easy to pronounce because it's hard
to pronounce. So 10. Okay.
Um, and this is a, an acronym.
The t stands for Torah,
which is a word that means instruction
or teaching. It's often translated law.
I think that's a very poor translation
means instruction way teaching.
Um, and that refers to the first
five books that you see listed here,
genesis through Deuteronomy.
The second division of the Bible
is referred to as Nivi Ean,
which is a Hebrew word for profits.
The,
the section of the profits is divided
really into two parts because there are
two types of writing in the
prophetic section of the Bible.
The first or former prophets continues
the kind of narrative prose account of
the history of Israel. Focusing on the
activities of Israel's profits. All right,
so, uh, the, the for the former
prophets are narrative texts.
The latter prophets are poetic
and or regular writings, um,
that bear the name of the prophet
to whom the writings are ascribed.
You have the three major prophets,
Isaiah, Jeremiah and Ezekiel,
and then the 12 minor prophets,
which in the Hebrew Bible get counted
together as one book because a lot of
those 12 are very small.
Okay?
The final section of the Bible is
referred to as to Veem in Hebrew,
which simply means writings.
And that's probably about 50% of the
Hebrew you're going to get in the whole
course. So please don't
be scared. You know,
I've got two or three other terms that'll
be useful along the way, but, but this,
there's really no need to know Hebrew.
I just want you to
understand why to NASC is,
is the word that's used to refer to
the Bible. So the two of them are,
the writings are really a miscellany.
They contain works of, of various types.
And the three parts correspond
very roughly to the process of,
of canonization or authoritativeness
for the community, the Torah,
the Torah probably reached a fixed
and authoritative status first.
Then the books are the profits.
And finally the writings.
And probably by the end of the
first century, all of this was um,
organized in some way. If you look at
the other handout, you'll see, however,
that any course on the Bible is going
to run immediately into the problem of
defining the object of study
because different bible
serve different communities
over the centuries.
One of the earliest translations of
the Hebrew Bible was a translation into
Greek known as the step two. Again,
it was written for the benefit.
It was translated for the benefit
of Jews who lived in Alexandria,
a Greek speaking Jews
who lived in Alexandria,
Egypt in the Hellenistic period before,
you know, somewhere around three,
the third or second century BCE.
The translation,
um,
has some divergences with the traditional
Hebrew text of the Bible as we now
have it,
including the order of the books.
And some of these things are charted
for you on the chart that I've,
I've handed out, um, the step two again,
the set two against rationale for
ordering the books is temporal. Um,
they've clustered books
genesis through Esther,
which tell if things past the books of
a job through the song of songs or the
Song of Solomon contained wisdom
that applies to the present.
And then the prophetic books
Isaiah to Malakai contained, um,
tell or tell a things future. Um,
some copies of the CEP to again,
contains some books not included
in the Hebrew Canon, but, uh,
accepted in the early Christian Canon.
The step two against the Greek
translation became by enlarge the Bible of
Christianity or more precisely, it became
the old testament of the Hebrew Bible.
The tr the church adopted the Hebrew
Bible as a precursor to it's largely
Hellenistic Gospels was,
uh,
an important association for it
with an old and respected tradition.
Our primary concern is the Bible of the
ancient Israelite and Jewish community.
The 24 books grouped in the Torah
profits and writing on that other sheet,
um, which is common to all bibles, right?
Whether Jewish or Christian, those 24,
the baseline common books.
So those are the 24 that we're going to
focus on because the term old testament
is a theologically loaded term.
Um,
it's sort of a suggest the doctrine that
the new testament has somehow fulfilled
or surpassed are antiquated.
The Bible of ancient Israel.
You're going to hear me refer to the
object of our study as the Hebrew Bible.
You may certainly use any other term
and you may certainly use the term old
testament.
As long as it's clear.
We're talking about this set of 24 bucks
and that's some of the other things
that are in the old testament that
aren't in the traditional Hebrew Bible.
It means you studying less so that
that might be a good thing. Um,
so it's fine with me if you want
to use that, but I will just,
I will prefer the more accurate
term Hebrew Bible. Um, also,
while we're on terminology,
you'll notice that I use BCE to refer to
the period before zero and CE to refer
to the period after zero, the common
era and before the common era. And,
and a lot of your secondary
readings and writings,
they'll be using the same thing.
It corresponds to what you know is BC
before Christ and Anno Domini right?
Add the year of our Lord. It's just a
non Christian centric way of dating. Um,
and a lot of your secondary readings,
you'll see it. So you should be,
you should get used to it.
BCE and CE before the common era and
the common era from earliest times
Christians made use of the Bible
but not always in Greek translation.
And the Christian Old Testament
contains some material,
not in the Hebrew Bible as I've mentioned
in some of these works are referred to
as the Apocrypha.
So you will have heard that term.
These are writings that were
composed somewhere around here,
sort of 200 BCE to 100 CE.
They were widely used
by Jews of the period.
They simply weren't considered to be
of the same status of the 24 books.
I'm glad they pick up the garbage
at 1110 on Wednesday mornings,
but they did become part of the
Canon of Catholic Christianity. Um,
and in the 16th century there,
canonical status was confirmed for the
Catholic Church with the renaissance and
the reformation.
Some Christians became interested
in Hebrew versions of the Bible.
They wanted to look at the Hebrew in
and not the Greek translation from the
Hebrew, um, Protestant.
The Protestant church denied canonical
status to the books of the Apocrypha. Um,
they said they were important for pious
instruction but excluded them from their
canon.
There are also some works you may know
of referred to as the PSEUDEPIGRAPHA.
We'll talk about some of these things in
a little more detail later from roughly
the same period,
tend to be a little more apocalyptic in
nature and they were never part of the,
the Jewish or the Catholic Canon.
Um,
but there are some eastern Christian
groups that have accepted them and their
cannon.
The point I'm trying to make is that
there are very many sacred cannons out
there that are cherished by very many
religious communities and they're all
designated bibles. Um, so again,
we're focusing on that core set of
24 books that are common to all, uh,
bibles everywhere. The 24 books of what
would in fact be the Jewish [inaudible].
Not only has there been variety regarding
the scope of the biblical Canon in
different communities, but there's been
some fluidity in the actual text itself.
We don't,
of course,
have any original copies
of these materials as they
came off the pen or whoever
it was who was writing them. And in fact,
before the middle of the 20th century,
our oldest manuscripts and fragments
of manuscripts of the Bible data to the
year 900,
that's an awful long distance,
right from the events they're talking
about. You gotta think about that, right?
You gotta think about that and what it
means and how were they transmitted and
preserve without the means of technology,
obviously, that we have today.
And what was so exciting in the middle
of the 20th century was the discovery of
the Dead Sea Scrolls. I'm sure
that you've heard of them. Um,
they brought about a dramatic
change in the state of our,
of our knowledge of a Hebrew man
or our Hebrew manuscript evidence.
The Dead Sea scrolls were found
in caves in the Judean desert. Um,
we used to think they were a
library of a sectarian community.
Now I think they think it was
a pottery factory or something.
So maybe they were just shoved there by
people fleeing the Roman conquest and in
70.
So that's up for grabs.
But we have this really great
collection of scrolls. Um,
and among them we have found an almost
complete copy of every book of the Bible.
Um,
or sorry,
a almost complete copy of the book of
Isaiah and then partial or copies or
fragments of all of the biblical
biblical books except maybe Esther.
Am I wrong about that?
I don't think there's an Esther from
camera and think that's the only one and
some of them date back.
So the fourth and third century.
So do you understand now why
everybody was so excited?
Suddenly we have evidence 13 or 1400 years
earlier that people were reading this
stuff. And you know, by and large, it's a
pretty constant textual tradition. Sure.
There are differences.
Sure. There are differences.
We see that our manuscripts are
not exactly like those fragments,
but there is a remarkable degree,
a high degree of correspondence so that
we really can speak of a relatively
stable textual trip tradition,
but still some fluidity.
And that's going to be interesting
for us to think about. Um,
there are many translations of the Bible,
but I would like you to
purchase for this course, um,
the Jewish Study Bible. So let me
turn now to just some of the details,
administrative organizational details
of the course, the secondary readings,
and that we'll be using.
Um,
I'm asking you to pick up
the Jewish Study Bible,
not only for the translation of the
Tanakh, which is a very good translation,
but because it contains a wonderful
scholarly articles in the back.
It used to be we had a course packet
for this course at it's two volumes.
And now with the purchase of this,
I've been able to really consolidate
and conduct to consolidate the readings.
They're really wonderful,
great introductions to the
individual books of the Bible.
And so I think you will find that
this will become like a Bible to you.
All right. Um, so you need to pick
that up and set the Yale Bookstore.
I also would like you to pick up this, um,
paperback. It's not terribly expensive.
We're going to be using
it in the first few weeks,
especially the ancient near east.
The other readings is secondary readings
for the course are all already online.
Um,
I will be also making them available at
Alegra for people who would like to just
purchase them already printed
out so you don't do it yourself.
But I know some people really
prefer to work online. So,
and certainly for the first week of
reading you can get started because it is
online.
I don't think things will be available
at allegro is until probably tomorrow
afternoon. Um, the
syllabus, as you can see,
it's pretty fixed syllabus,
but it's divided into a schedule of
lectures and then a schedule of readings.
All right, so understand that there
are two distinct things there.
It's not just all the scheduled lectures.
Last few pages are a schedule of the
actual readings and the assignment that
you'll have for the weekend and for
next week's lectures are the readings by
Kaufman. Really, really need you
to read that before the next class.
And I want you to read it critically.
Um,
Calvin's ideas are important but they're
also overstated and so they're going to
be interesting for us.
We're going to wrestle with his claims
quite a bit during the course of the
semester.
The secondary readings are heavier at
the beginning of the course when we are
reading very small segments of Biblical
text that will shift right towards the
end of the course. You're
going to be reading, you know,
a couple of books in the Bible and maybe
a 10 page article is secondary reading.
So it's front loaded
with secondary readings.
So you'll want to get started on the
Kaufman because for the first few weeks
it's quite a bit of secondary reading,
but we're covering just a
few chapters of Bible, uh,
each time and the first
few weeks sections.
We're going to be doing this online
registration thing that I've never done
before. So I hope it works. We do have
three teaching fellows for this course.
I hope that will be sufficient. Um, uh,
actually if the teaching fellows could
stand up so people could at least
recognize you, that would be wonderful.
Benny else, anyone wants to volunteer?
We could have a fourth. Okay. So we have
two in the back there. We have tutor,
a tutor,
Salah raising his hand and Sfi Novik here.
They will be running regular
uh, discussion sections and
then Christine Garroway.
Um, we'll be running a
writing requirement section.
I don't think that was listed in the
blue book but it should have been listed
online that there is,
it is possible to fulfill your writing
skills requirement through this course.
Um, so Christine will be running
that. We will bring on Monday.
So please have your schedules as
well formed as they are on Monday.
We will put up times and we will take
a straw poll to figure out if we can
accommodate everybody within the times.
One more extremely important announcement.
It's on your syllabus,
but I want to underline it even more
than it is already underlined and bold
faced.
Uh,
I want to underline the importance of
the section discussions in this course.
In fact it's really wrong to
call them section discussions.
It sounds like they're,
you're discussing the lectures and the
readings and you're really not that
section. Discussions are a
compliment to the lectures.
What I mean is this is an awfully big
thing to spend just one semester studying
and I can't do it all.
And in my lectures I'll be trying to set
broad themes and patterns and describe
what's going on,
but I want you to have the experience of
actually sitting and reading chunks of
texts and struggling with
that and understanding the
history of interpretation
of passages and and how so many of
the important things have happened
historically because of people's efforts
to understand this text. So in sections,
a large part of the focus in section
will be on specific passages,
reading and struggling with the text,
the kind of thing I can't do in lecture.
This is important because your final
paper assignment will be a paper and
exercise and exegesis and interpretation.
The skills that you will
need for that paper.
I am fairly certain are not things that
you would have acquired in high school.
And like we have some upperclassmen,
I don't know,
but maybe not even some upperclassmen
will have acquired here yet. Um,
exegesis is a very particular kind of
skill and the teaching fellows will be
introducing you to two
methods of exegesis. Um,
so it's really a training ground for
the final paper and we have found that
people don't succeed in the course in
the final paper without the training they
get in section discussion,
which is why I'm section participation
is worth 10% of your grade.
However,
if there are repeated unexcused absences,
there'll be an adjustment in the grade
calculation and it will be worth 20 to
25% of your grade and it will be a
negative grade also. And believe me,
this is a favor to you.
It is definitely a favor to you.
It's sections are critically
important in this course. Okay.
So if you have any questions,
I can hang around for a few minutes,
but thank you for coming.
We'll see you Monday.